hey guys I'm riding rights hey guys I'm
salamu news so we're gonna check out a
trailer for a Robin Williams movie where
there's a bunch of idiots out there on
the internet who are like wait how did
this come out I thought he was dead
like it's like people don't realize
films take whatever yes anyway it's
called Boulevard it's rated R for
language and sexual content it's from
the guy who directed Channing Tatum's
fighting movie I hope this movie is guys
well they should think about making a
change from time to time
I think you're not aware of far yes
suddenly sixty years old you want to
give me right that's the demonic in me
right really swamp to work here don't no
way to get to this if I stay late
separate lives separate rooms
need to talk to the hell out of my house
I'm just trying to help
I tried to call you today
hey princess
I can't fall you know you can
what future
never
this is time for us to be in the real
world
you know it's kind of weird is that I
heard him and his wife we're sleeping in
separate rooms when he like died so it
was kind of weird that that was also in
the movie like it seemed like this role
probably was something he really related
to do which is super sad well it's a
good outlet at least I mean Robin
Williams looks like they have like these
reviews posted in the trailer but you
can't always believe that but from what
I've seen at the clips Robin Williams
does look like he's doing a solid job I
was sad to see that like you know he
passed away and then a lot of his films
were just like stupid comedies so it's
cool to see that this is you know a real
dramatic performance with a cool message
behind it you know about it doesn't
matter how old you are but start living
your life you know it's like maybe it
takes you a while to get to that
realization but take risks stand up for
yourself take chances believe in what
you want to believe in you know it's one
of those movies that kind of reminds me
of the more you learn to love yourself
and feel that love the more you'll be
able to share that and communicate it
with others as a book because this guy
starts off as kind of like lonely and
depressed and everything is routine yeah
he's really distant within himself so
he's distant to others I thought it was
gonna go down some like homosexual at
first which I wouldn't have minded but
it's I mean it might that could be kind
of an underlying thing we don't know yet
all we know is this event seemed to make
him change yeah yeah it's kind of
reminded me of welcome to the Rileys
have you ever seen them it's the one
movie that I believe Kristen Stewart
actually did like really good job in but
it's basically like this husband like
sees this stripper girl it's basically
like him trying to do nice things for
Kristen Stewart as like this or it's a
clue but it's really sad because in the
end like you can't end up helping
everybody ends up helping himself by at
least trying did you just give away the
ending no okay let's hope not now it's
cool to see Bob Odenkirk in this you
know like we've all gotten the
impression
him from like better call Saul Breaking
Bad just a specific image but more than
just the facial hair and glasses it
looks like he's doing a much more calm
more sincere role because he comes from
the comedy world as well so it's cool to
see like these two comedians balancing
each other out in a more subtle type of
drama and they're both a really great
actors like I would totally watch this
movie just because of those two and to
see it's that every time I look at his
face in this trailer I can see the pain
like that is not acting that is just
like feeling that's part of what made
his art so good was that there was a lot
of real-life resemblance to it despite
how we went out it's still cool to see
that he was able to use it for a good
purpose because a roll like this if done
properly and it looks like it's done
really well you know beyond like the
Oscar nominations and all that it could
be something that's really uplifting to
others and really inspiring to others
and they seem to be capital I one thing
I'm not liking from trailers with Robin
Williams stuff is I feel like they
capitalize off his death too much but in
a way saying this is his final dramatic
performance if it is a strong
performance it could be even more
powerful because he did pass away so
this because it's about living you know
I'm hoping this is in some way
inspirational yeah and not just
completely sappy melodrama yeah let's
hope not and the film looks shot really
well the cinematography looks really
good anyway guys thanks for tuning in to
this channel if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can follow a Sally's Channel
salamander Sally it's a good channel
with good stuff on there and she has
boobs and you could check us out on
Facebook Instagram Twitter and vine
where if we get enough followers we can
get more product placement that's right
we've already gotten at people thanks
for the help
yeah Sally needs it so watch your
channel more so she can get product
placement that's the goal that's all who
youtubers care about Nick and money I
miss the old YouTube no no you knew
YouTube's better it's about making money
less work example people used to do
short films comedy sketches
now and just do a bunch of reaction
videos challenges thank you know it's
simple easy [ __ ] easy [ __ ] and that
brings in the money I have a lot of
self-respect